you're on your eighth album and it's
selling right if it's breaking records
everywhere right now what makes it so
unique you know I think on this album
you know we put a lot of thought into
what we wanted to do before we ever got
in the studio a lot of times we just
kind of go in and you know we find a lot
of songs that we think are cool we go
and we make the record and and that's it
and I think on this album we really paid
attention to to finding great songs and
really kind of had a game plan going in
what we wanted to do we got somebody
else to to mix this record yet somebody
that we hadn't used before come in to
mix the record and you know felt like to
me for the first time in a long time the
album sounded like what we sound like
loved and you know they mix us like like
we get mixed live and how we're used to
sounding and and I just think the
overall sound of the record was just you
know it was one of those things that I
think we knew in the studio there was
something really cool there was some
different sounding songs you know you
make it easy and things like that that
were a little different sounding songs
and we put out in the past so I think
changing it up a little bit here and
there and and you know eight albums in a
lot of times you got to find ways to get
creative and you know you feel like a
lot of your ideas you've already used on
other albums and so yeah yeah and so
it's just you know I think just really
focusing on that and trying to make sure
that we went in this time and didn't
make an album that we felt like we had
made already you know and and so at the
end of the day you know we came out of
there with what I feel like is one of my
best albums we've ever know how you feel
about that yes there's a song I can't
remember the name of the song girls like
you I think is there's a bit of an R&B
feel to it yeah that's actually our new
single too yeah so but you know little
things like that like little little
little answer lines and stuff that we
did in that I mean it's just you know
it's different me you got drowns of
whiskey which is really you know more
traditional country you got you make it
easy that was really kind of bluesy and
and then you know girl like you is a
little more R&B and
a little more on the pop side so you
know I feel like there was a lot of I
mean my influences they're scattered all
across the board I mean for me growing
up I mean it was in the country world it
was Alabama and George Strait and Ronnie
Milsap and guys like that you know it's
a big fan of a lot of the 80's rock
bands you know def def leppard Guns
N'Roses all those guys you know Seger
Mellencamp and then where I'm from
southern rock is huge so all my brothers
and Lynyrd Skynyrd and you know so
there's my influences are scattered all
over the place and and I feel like on
this album we were able to you know pull
in a lot of those different influences
and use them on the record to where you
can hear them in different songs and
that's cool yeah that's what about the
elements like different elements to
every song and I think that's why it's
such a big celebration and down--so
whiskey I mean come on if you hear that
song at a bar it's so depressing but I
was just moving around I'm just gonna
push myself back but that song has
Miranda I got you
go ahead can I talk about yeah I'm movin
Miranda Lambert's on it uh how did that
conversation happen to you callers they
have this wicked song for you now won't
you be part of it well Miranda and I
we've known each other for a long time
and used to tour together we had
recorded a song on my second album that
was called grown woman and she used to
come out and we would perform it every
night and so I always thought our voices
just sounded really cool you know
together and and so I'd wanted to do
something with her and I had a song in
mind that that I had already cut and I
sent it to her to see how she how she
liked it and you know it wasn't a duet I
was just thinking maybe we could turn it
into one and so she wasn't crazy about
the song it was definitely a different
kind of song and rounds of whiskey and
so after talking to her a little bit and
kind of seeing where her head was that I
was like well you know I got this I got
this other song I think is gonna be
perfect
for what you're saying and so I sent
that to her and it was John's whiskey
and and
you know once I sent her that she was
wrote back she's like I love this and
and that was it you know got her in the
studio and I knew it was gonna turn out
great once she got on it just because
like I said we had we'd sang together
before I knew how our voices sound
together and so once we got her on it it
was you know tell people all the time it
was a it was a great song before she was
on it but her you know coming on board
it just kind of took it to a new place
would you collaborate with another
female country star yeah a recognition
for them right now love you you look at
my career over the years I mean that's
one thing that I've always loved to do
is collaborate with other artists you
know Kelly and Luke and air church we
did that song with them and Ludacris and
Kelsea Ballerini we had a song with her
on my last album so you know that's
something that I'm always up for any
time and you know I think it a lot of
times boils down to having the right
song and the right voice for that song
and you know so I think it's just kind
of one of those I'm always open so we'll
see what happens when you're on the road
do you think about your next album do
you think about other songs you start
writing on the road and yeah I mean
we're out here constantly you know
listening to songs I'm for me that kind
of never ends so as soon as we're done
recording one album we pretty much
immediately start listening for songs
for the next album and you know as we
start piling those up a little bit and
we feel like we got enough songs to go
in the studio and start working on the
next album we get in the studio and kind
of get the process started so we got two
more weeks left on the tour and and then
we're off the road for a few months and
and so at the end of this year we're
gonna go in start working on a new album
and you know kind of have it ready to go
and by the time this one's done we'll
have one in the can ready to go so I
think everyone's collaborate with cardi
B I mean call me that could be a great
combination right there my wife loves
her now on top of your tour we're having
a baby
diapers again congratulations thank you
very much she's good she's uh you know
she's got her hands full right now
usually they're out on the road with me
okay so they're out here most of the
time but her her parents came in to town
this weekend so she stayed at home and
and she's got our nine-month old Memphis
he's at home with her so yeah she's got
her hands full with him right now but
here in a few months we're gonna have
two of them under a year and a half so
it'll be be interesting to see what
happens in our house if Memphis looking
forward to a brother I don't know he's
getting a sister so it's a girl but you
know he's he's cool man he's a cool kid
and and whenever we're we take him
anywhere any season other kid he's
always wanting to stop and kind of
interact with him so I think he's gonna
be great with her that's great you know
what I love the fact that you guys
started a conversation using your
platform about the struggles you had
with IVF and getting pregnant why was
that important to you well you know I to
me that was one of those things where I
kind of let my wife you know take
control that I'm like you know I've
always been pretty private you know with
my personal life for the most part and
and you know but for her I mean it was
something that she you know what didn't
shy away from talking about and so you
know it was just I think for us wanting
to have a child and you know it not
happening and and having to go through
IVF that process I mean it's it's a you
know it can be a great thing I mean
obviously it was because we ended up
having our son and and and now this baby
too so you know but for a couple years
there it was you know it's a roller
coaster ride and it's it's really tough
mentally just you know going through
that stuff and it's it's it's tough and
you see people that you know they save
up and try to do this one time and if it
doesn't work that's gonna it and and
it's just you know it's just
heartbreaking a lot of times but but
then we're on the flip side of that it's
it's helped a lot of people be able to
have children that probably wouldn't
have been able to so it's you know it's
a really cool thing yeah it happens to
so many people so for you to even
mention it it's helped so many people
that conversation yeah the second time I
was something it was fine it was just
straight up right like no no issues with
the IBF no wait no we I mean we used IVF
the second thing - yeah so but my wife
had endometriosis so that was like a big
problem with her in the in the beginning
and then I you know had a little surgery
to like fix all that stuff and whatever
and and so you know once that was done
you know that that seemed to be like one
of the biggest problems so you know but
like I said it just we ended up you know
it was it was rough for a couple years
it was really up-and-down roller coaster
thing but but then you know we got him
out of the deal so and a little girl in
the way so will they come on the road
with you next year yeah they're always
out like I said they're typically out
for the most part I'm actually having a
brand new bus built for you know yeah
well it's like got their own books in
there and we can kind of zip them in
they don't fall out into the floor so
that's gotta have that and say yeah
we'll have it rigged up ready to go next
year with two babies on board it's it's
it's funny my bus used to have like
liquor bottle bottle beer bottle now
it's like baby bottle beer bottle